the problem is most people want to go
viral and they'll say [__] they don't
even believe just to get more views
right that's the real [__] problem it
feels like at any moment around any band
we could get
thoughtful about the content we're
putting out right the way I look at
canceled is if your intent is good right
there's no sustained cancel like this
sure do I think that given the nature of
our society right now that you may have
Micro moments of course but if it's not
true if you're not trying to hurt anyone
if you don't want that on anyone it's
almost impossible for you to be canceled
people want to go viral so they're
willing to compromise their intent for
virality and that's why people get
[__] up so intent matters content is
everything